y hoy en directo vamos a londres con
nuestra corresponsal luisa pulido porque
hay elecciones municipales y autonómicas
precisamente en estos países aunque las
votaciones son en inglaterra escocia
gales e irlanda del norte estas últimas
son las más llamativas porque por
primera vez las encuestas apuntan a un
triunfo del partido sinn fein el brazo
político del extinto ejército
republicano irlandés el ira por sus
siglas en inglés luisa cuéntanos cómo
podría cambiar reino unido- si el sinn
fein es el partido más votado de irlanda
del norte
en el futuro los republicanos del sinn
fein podrían buscar un referendo para la
reunificación de la isla de irlanda es
decir la independencia de irlanda del
norte del reino unido- lo que supone por
supuesto una amenaza a la estabilidad y
a la unión de este país que también lo
integran inglaterra gales y escocia
aunque es cierto que la reunificación de
la isla de irlanda no hace parte de las
prioridades actuales del sinn fein si ha
sido una de sus promesas históricas si
las encuestas aciertan y el sinn fein se
convierte en el partido más votado en
irlanda del norte- entonces sería
histórico porque podría por primera vez
conformar gobierno y es que en 100 años
de existencia de esta región británica
ha sido en esencia unionista es decir
quiere estar dentro del reino unido-
también sería histórico este triunfo por
lo que significa que el otrora conocido
como el brazo político del ira el sinn
fein
el líder del gobierno por el acuerdo de
paz de 1998 que trajo paz política a
esta zona se estableció que en el
gobierno regional de irlanda del norte
habría un gobierno de coalición del sinn
fein y de los unionistas
generalmente el partido democrático
unionista ha sido el jefe pero lo que
sucedería ahora la diferencia sería que
el sinn fein sería ahora el líder pues
ya miraremos si logra ser el líder por
ahora cuéntanos cuál es el impacto de
estas elecciones en el gobierno de boris
johnson
el nuevo mapa político que dejará estas
elecciones municipales determinará el
futuro político del primer ministro
boris johnson cuya credibilidad de
autoridad ha estado fuertemente golpeada
por el escándalo del partido gheit pero
también será el termómetro del gobierno
para medir qué tan dañino ha sido
justamente este escándalo de las fiestas
que se habrían realizado en el complejo
del gobierno y de down instruir durante
los confinamientos por la pandemia del
coi 19 sumado a la crisis del aumento
del costo de vida en el país si el
partido laborista otros partidos de
oposición ganan más gobiernos locales
entonces el partido conservador podría
convocar a una moción de confianza sobre
su jefe y dejaría boris johnson en la
puerta de downing street hasta el
momento del partido conservador ha
mantenido el apoyo a johnson pese a que
ha sido multado por la policía por este
escándalo
pero si los resultados que se empezarán
a conocer en las próximas horas no son
favorables entonces esta situación y la
suerte de boris johnson podría cambiar
rápidamente estaremos atentos a esos
resultados luisa gracias por gracias por
la información y seguimos con deportes